and uh in some cultures you know in kind
of modern western secular cultures
what's called weird that's western
educated industrialized uh rich
democracies men and women tend to
converge and take care of offspring more
together but in most cultures
men hold their kids like whatever 15
minutes a day women hold their kids you
know nine times as long as as men do and
they always know that they're the the
mother of their offspring for example
and so you should see a lot of
differences also in domains that have
everything to do
with child rearing and
there's also this difference in the
kinds of roles that men and women have
had in terms of hunting gathering
and
seeking out maids warfare
it's never been the case that a band of
women have gotten together with spears
and hand axes to go and kidnap the men
from a neighboring group and have sex
with them like that's never ever
happened
uh you know this idea there's kind of a
a fantasy and i think it's i the more
i've learned about kind of leftist
ideology the more i think it comes from
a really good place it would be
wonderful if human nature was so
malleable that literally women could be
socialized to go to war to whatever
i mean that wouldn't be a great outcome
but it'd be great if human nature was
that malleable so i think it comes from
a really nice place but i don't really
think that um human nature especially
sex differences uh are that malleable
and so you see these kinds of of
differences uh so
if you look at the
the research
what you see is that there's this kind
of minimization of personality
differences so for example
if you look at extraversion which is one
of the big five personality factors
men and women don't really differ much
on extraversion but if you look at the
internal facets of extroversion you'll
see women are more warm than men are and
men are more assertive and sensation
seeking than women are
and so there's a scientist named marco
del giudice at university of new mexico
he's my evolutionary psych colleague and
he did a really great paper called the
distance between mars and venus and he
said these you know these
characteristics that men and women have
they don't occur in a vacuum these
personality characteristics they
converge and they correlate together and
so if you look at cluster of all the
masculine personality characteristics
and all the feminine personality
characteristics they actually is a big
difference between them and that's
averaging across gay men and gay women
as well so there's still a big
difference between these two groups and
if you look at the personality factors
as they are like extroversion
agreeableness etc then you'll see
smaller differences or if you look at
very specific things
like if you for example um
what's her name cordelia fine did
testosterone rex and she said yes uh
it's true that in these personality
factors they say men are much more
risk-taking than women are but they
didn't ask about certain kinds of risks
like what about the risk of cooking a
souffle that you've never cooked before
i'm like that's
that's not that nobody's going to kill
you
bad souffle right
so um one thing that i've always been
fascinated with is the you know how the
premise of well women like a bad boy is
that
scientifically true
and if it is why so
um
yeah so i think that is true but
well so it depends on the kind of
environment you live in
so there's some idea that you actually
you're malleable in the inter you know
in the beginning years of your life as
to how much you like these kind of what
are called dark triad characteristics so
dark triad is narcissism
machiavellianism and psychopathy
and those are you know how great you
think you are
accurate
exactly um narcissists are actually
considered more attractive than other
people who aren't narcissists really
probably because their narcissism is
somewhat informed by their actual self
their actual main value what we call may
value so i think more attractive people
are more likely i mean attractiveness
and narcissism do correlate like
objectively if you think somebody's more
attractive they're more likely to be
narcissists and then whenever i fill out
a narcissistic personality inventory
they're like would things be better if
you ruled the world i'm like well yes
objectively
that's true
but um so these kinds of personality
characteristics so one idea it kind of
floating around is that if you are in a
volatile environment so if you're an
environment where let's say you don't
have a father around then
you're getting cues from the environment
that either your dad's dead or that this
is not the kind of environment where men
invest in their kids
for example
or also if you're an environment where
you see people deceiving each other or
cheating each other so what's the best
thing to do in an environment like that
is to have babies that are also going to
be able to be good liars and good at
deceiving and manipulating other people
you don't want to find the most
agreeable nice guy in the world to have
kids with if you're in an environment
that is volatile in this way and you see
this
this kind of dichotomy about what women
like in in romance novels so in romance
novels which are the best-selling books
on the planet
what happens is the woman falls in love
with a man who's this bad boy rogue uh
what are the top you know they're
pirates or thieves or whatever right and
then he becomes so devoted to her that
he can express
this deep devotion to her and he's nice
to her and agreeable to her where he
isn't to anybody else and that is sort
of this feminine fantasy is to be with
somebody who has the capacity to
manipulate and [ __ ] over and deceive
other people but doesn't to her as so in
love with her that he treats her really
well and her family and her kids really
really well and that is that's what
really optimally i think women want
because that's the kind of phenotype
that's the kind of man who could succeed
in any environment and he would make the
kind of kids that could conceive
succeed in any environment so he would
be nice to her but he would also be able
to protect her from the external danger
and provide or whatever is that
evolutionary yeah that that kind of
thing but if you're really in a really
involved environment you want somebody
who can't yet like [ __ ] over other
people
so that's like what you optimally want
and even women who say like oh i want a
man who's generous yeah you want a man
who's generous but you don't want to
come home and find a [ __ ] sleeping on
your sofa because you decided to bring
one home you want a man who's generous
to you you want a man who's generous to
your family you want a man who always
tells you you know potentially that
you're right but there's like a whole
manosphere red pill thing about how much
women need pushback and how women
actually test to make sure
that men that they're with actually
still have these kind of bad
characteristics that they can still fend
for themselves in that kind of way
really tell us about that that sounds
interesting
i haven't heard about this stuff so
uh i'm writing i'm sort of writing a
book and i'm probably won't go into very
much but i've started reading some of
this red pill
stuff because i just so if anyone
doesn't know including me what is it you
don't know what red pill is uh i'm
familiar with red pill in the sense of
people who might have been left-leaning
becoming less left-leaning there's a lot
of different red pills that you can
possibly take that's why i'm starting to
get the sense that's not the one you're
talking about no that's not the one i'm
talking about um red pill is a
it's it's men so that can think the
common wisdom is that women have it
worse than men women are oppressed
compared to men and the red pill like
for example in this like red pill
documentary says that actually women do
have some advantages and these are
underplayed relative to men's advantages
and not only that but that women also
do manipulative things to men in order
to get their way that women have kind of
secret power wait is this a cassie j
documentary yeah i have seen it and i've
just asked you a question
about something i've seen as if i've not
you know there's extra red pill stuff
there's also like red pill stuff about
you know what's called [ __ ] testing so
yeah
when women when and and you're i guess
you're blissfully ignorant of the way
you're learning about you mean
that's good i'm happily married for a
long time now so he doesn't even realize
he's getting played that's how he feels
all of this information just not to know
what's happening and just to be happy
with my life so please tell me what's
wrong with that um so yeah so women
women whatever
do something called [ __ ] testing and
they do a variety of things to see kind
of what the boundaries are like how much
they can get away with how generous a
man is going to be with them how
compliant he is to her demands
especially if they're
unreasonable so
if you make an unreasonable demand of a
man is he just gonna say yes i'll do
that or will he you experience some kind
of pushback so kind of testing a man to
see
if he has the kind of
status whatever balls whatever you want
to call it in order to push back against
you and not give in to your every whim
and
i think
and i i find that women's kind of
self-help books are very often
like you go girl and you're amazing as
you are and there's nothing you need to
do to change in any way shape or form
and somebody will love you just as you
are whereas i find men's self-help books
are very much
saying you should work out you should be
doing playing chess you should be trying
to sharpen your mind and you also need
to play this game that women are playing
whereas i really haven't read very you
know and i've been trying to read some
women's self-help books that say no you
are a woman and you are playing a game
but you're deceiving yourself about
these games that you are playing and i
find that i'm very self-aware about the
kinds of
ways that i am
testing things out and seeing where men
are at with me
[Music]